vaccines are celebrated for their part
in fighting disease but a growing group
of people seem to believe that they
endanger our health instead of
protecting it the internet is full of
stories about allergic reactions the
onset of disabilities and even death
following vaccination appointments and
it's true vaccines can have side effects
let's look at how they work and how
dangerous they really are your immune
system is a complex army of billions of
cells soldiers intelligent cells and
weapons factories every day you're
attacked countless times but you're
immune soldiers alone usually deal with
that so you don't even notice if an
infection become serious though
our intelligence cells gather Intel
about the attackers and activate our
weapons factories you know the weapon
antibodies they're like targeted
missiles produced specifically to combat
the invader unfortunately this process
takes several days to complete that
gives intruders a lot of time to do
damage contrary to popular wisdom what
doesn't kill you doesn't make you
stronger our bodies really don't want to
fight serious wars are over and over so
our immune system came up with an
ingenious way to get stronger and
stronger over time if we fight an enemy
that is dangerous enough to trigger our
heavy weapons our immune system
automatically creates memory cells
memory cells remain in our body for
years in a deep sleep they do nothing
but remember when an enemy attacks for a
second time the slumbering memory cells
awaken and order coordinated attacks and
the production of antibodies this is so
fast and effective that many infections
you beat once will never make you sick
again you might even be immune against
them forever which is also why little
kids aren't constantly ill
they don't have enough memory cells yet
and this beautiful natural mechanism is
what we build on when we use vaccines
how vaccines work as greatest memory
cells are obtaining them through an
infection is unpleasant and sometimes
dangerous vaccines are a way of tricking
our bodies into making memory cells and
becoming immune to a disease they
pretend to be a dangerous infection one
way of doing this is to inject invaders
that can't do harm for example by
killing them or by ripping them into
pieces our immune systems deal with
these kinds of vaccines pretty easily
sometimes it's necessary to make our
immune system work harder though to
produce even more memory cells live
vaccines are the real deal an enemy that
can punch back is a bigger challenge
than a dead one
but this also sounds like a sort of
horrible idea what if the germs win to
avoid that we read a sort of weak cousin
of the real germ in the lab just
powerful enough to annoy the immune
system and create enough memory cells
okay so these are the basic principles
of vaccine use they provoke a natural
reaction in our bodies that makes us
become immune against very dangerous
diseases some like the flu virus mutates
so often that we need a new vaccine
every year but most vaccines protect us
for years or even a lifetime but there's
a catch like everything in life vaccines
have another side side effects what are
they and what happens if your child
develops one the risks of vaccines it's
complicated to directly compare the side
effects of vaccines with the effects of
diseases for example hundreds of
millions of people are vaccinated
against measles in the West but there
were only 83,000 cases in Europe in 2018
so with numbers that different even mild
side effects can seem scary compared
to the bad effects of a disease that we
don't see as much anymore
before the measles vaccine became
available in 1963 virtually every single
child on earth contracted measles at
some point an estimated 135 million
cases in the 1950s every single year but
our measles really that dangerous in the
year 2019 with our advanced health care
and new technologies are they worth the
risk of vaccine side-effects let's do a
thought experiment based on real numbers
imagine a developed country in a
parallel world
it has good healthcare but people stop
vaccinating in this scenario let's say
ten million children caught measles what
happens nine million eight hundred
thousand or 98% will get a high fever
and a very unpleasant rash up to 800,000
of them or 8% will suffer from dangerous
diarrhea 700,000 or 7% will suffer from
an ear infection which can lead to
permanent hearing loss 600,000 kids or
6% will suffer from pneumonia the most
dangerous effect of measles it alone
will kill 12,000 children up to 10,000
children or 0.1% will get encephalitis
2500 kids or 0.025 percent will contract
sspe a disease where the measles virus
lingers in their brain and kills them a
few years later taken together around
2.5 million children will suffer from
somewhat serious effects from measles
and about 20,000 children will be killed
by measles it doesn't stop here though
the kids who beat measles are left with
a severely damaged immune system that
needs a lot of time to regenerate time
for other diseases to do further damage
aside from that what's almost guaranteed
is that your kids will have a really bad
time for about two weeks okay but what
about vaccines it's only fair to look at
these risks too so let's repeat our
thought experiment but this time we
vaccinate ten million children with MMR
what would theoretically happen here
after being vaccinated about 10 million
kids around ten percent get a fever
five hundred thousand or five percent
will get a mild rash up to one hundred
or 0.001 percent might have a serious
allergic reaction and will have to be
treated up to ten boys or 0.0001% might
get inflammation of the genitalia and up
to ten kids in total or 0.0001 percent
might get the most serious side effect
and sefa lightest so we vaccinated ten
million kids in total around one hundred
and twenty had side effects that were
somewhat serious thanks to good medical
treatment in developed regions almost
all of them will be fine
what about autism the connection of
autism and vaccines stems from one
source that has been disproven a
countless times will link to further
reading and videos in the description
but in 2019 it's fair to say that
vaccines do not cause autism all right
but what about deaths it's really hard
to say if even a single one of our 10
million vaccinated kids would die we
really did look hard and talk to a lot
of different experts
if we ignore self-reporting we could
only come up with a tiny handful of
documented cases for all the hundreds of
millions of children who received the
MMR vaccine since 1971 measles are many
many thousands of times more dangerous
for your child than even the absolute
worst case of vaccine side-effects
you have to search for lethal vaccines
side-effects with a huge magnifying
glass and even then it's very hard to
find confirmed cases while deaths from
measles are real and easy to find in
2017 alone
110,000 people died from measles
worldwide statistically today 300
children will die of measles one since
this video started you can compare
vaccines to seatbelts are there weird
freak accidents where someone gets
killed by their seatbelt well yes
but do you personally think it's safer
to not put a seatbelt on your kid wait a
second what if your kid is actually
allergic what if none of the things
we've said applies to your specific
situation in this case you need to
become the greatest vaccination promoter
of all because if your children can't be
vaccinated only the collective can
protect them this is called herd
immunity and it's the only thing that
can protect your unvaccinated child herd
immunity means that enough people are
immune to a disease that it can't spread
and dies before it reaches its victims
but to accomplish this for measles alone
95% of the people around you need to be
vaccinated conclusion the problem with
the debate about vaccines is that it's
not fought on a level playing field
while the pro vaccine side argues with
studies and statistics the arguments
against them are usually a wild mixture
of gut feeling anecdotes and
misinformation and feelings are often
immune to facts will not convince
anybody by screaming at them but we
can't hide from the reality of what anti
vaccine conspiracies do they kill babies
too young to be vaccinated they kill
healthy children that are just unlucky
they bring serious diseases back from
the verge of extinction and the biggest
side effect of vaccines is fewer dead
children vaccines are one of the most
powerful tools we have to eradicate the
monsters that most of us have already
forgotten
let's not bring the beasts back
[Music]
you
you
you